l'aéroport de nocibé arbore les couleurs
nationales à moins de deux semaines du
60e anniversaire de l'indépendance de
madagascar sur base de la liste de la
cellule de crise de l'ambassade de
france
les 58 premiers inscrits de nocibé ont
décroché leur place sur ce premier vol
exceptionnel à destination de la réunion
la majorité d'entre eux ont pour
destination finale paris la plus de
température des passagers et on leur dit
de mettre le masque est normalement la
distance de 1 mètre cette date est
respectable mais des fois les pertes à
gmac ses marchés plus tard avec une
soixantaine de tdr disponibles pour
gérer l'état d'urgence sanitaire à
l'aéroport pas d'épuisement du précieux
stocks en l'absence de cas suspect
identifié par le thermomètre chaque
passager et par contre dans l'obligation
de remplir sa déclaration sur l'honneur
pour atterrir sur le sol français n'ont
jamais arabe ceux qui n'ont pas marché
décolle pas de la réunion cathy simon
est arrivé le 4 mars à nancy b pour
effectuer du bénévolat dans la région où
il retourne chez moi pour peut-être
allez-vous c'est un petit peu c'est une
auxiliaire de lille aucune balle qu'il
ya une sclérose en table mes vacances le
tout très très chèrement la petite
auxiliaire de vie à mi temps en temps
vous dire que manutan gaiement germans
géreront manger que j'ai des supers
copains qui ont une cagnotte pour me
payer le billet de retour pour moi je
rentrais pas chez moi
la première fois depuis la fermeture des
frontières il ya trois mois
carn avion de passagers s'apprêtent à
décoller de cette triste en aller simple
c'est d'un aller-retour à ça reste très
cher
pour entrer notre vol retour qu'on avait
initialement évidemment et les parents
possèdent un surplus d'eau
une 3e
500 euros sur notre voyage ce ne sont
pas des vols réguliers du fait que les
avions partent plein à plat mais
reviennent un vide donc automatiquement
il faut payer si on peut dire un aller
retour pour un simple billet au total
plus de 170 personnes ont décollé de
diego suarez
maj un gars et nocibé ces dernières 48
heures donc maintenant que qui n'y a
plus de confinement en france je veux je
pense qu'à un peu plus de demandes de
départ depuis la fermeture des
frontières
la cellule de crise de l'ambassade de
france a reçu 7000 appels et a pu
constituer une liste d'attentes de 2000
ressortissants européens bloqués à
madagascar silence sur paris mais
normalement il n'ya pas de 14 heures
certains candidats au départ ont pris
l'initiative de constituer un e mail des
listes dans l'espoir de faciliter les
décollages des provinces extractives
itie leur matelas que c'est
c'est à dire par là
battus à brême qui a déjà bouclé le
parcours
je crois que c'est bien qu'ils aient des
gens qui se préoccupent de leurs
concitoyens et et ses listes bien
entendu il faut les regrouper au sein du
consulat puisque c'était le mot d'ordre
c'est difficile de d'avoir plusieurs
listes qui circulent un peu partout
ne sachant pas apprécié on peut faire ou
pas un avion une centaine de personnes
seraient encore dans la tente d'un
prochain départ rien qu'à nocibé
[Musique]